uh for people who don't know uh give me
because you came to America as an
immigrant right yeah I came here when I
was 11 months old I was born in Valencia
Venezuela and uh would you end up coming
to Florida no actually I moved to
Houston okay for a year so me and my
family just immigrated story you know uh
we were in a garage and about like uh 10
months after we moved to Houston we uh
you know we dipped out to Florida but
what people don't know and like this is
probably the first time I'll see it on
camera is like I actually came to
America because I had like a you know
like a life-threatening surgery in my
brain because when I was a kid I hit my
head on a metal bed so when I hit my
middle when I got hit in the head I
basically uh like no one knew because it
was an internal wound [ __ ] so I had I
started having internal bleeding in my
brain so then my aunt comes home drunk
at three in the morning um from a
nightclub basically hears me crying in
the middle of night picks me up and I'm
purple
I go to the hospital and at the time you
know Venezuela the health care is not
the greatest over there so they're like
oh he's having an allergic reaction just
give them some antibiotics and he'll be
fine but then my mom's like no
something's wrong so it took me to a
private Clinic my dad before was going
back and forth between the U.S and
America so he had an American Express
credit card so he put the whole
operation on American Express and that
was making it made him go bankrupt and
that's the reason why we came to this
country [ __ ] yeah so then we moved to
Houston because my dad had a friend over
there we stayed in his garage for like a
10 months 11 months and then my dad was
like damn this is this is us it's not
our Vibes I'm gonna try to go to Florida
um there's more Spanish people there so
that's why we went to Florida and I
moved to Fort Lauderdale and then like
in my later years in high school I kind
of like started making my shift to Miami
damn yeah so it's almost like
I was definitely amazing the biggest
gifting curse situation like yeah yeah
had a crazy traumatic surgery but if it
weren't for that you probably wouldn't
be here right no yeah and then it's nice
because it's like it always gives me
perspective of like damn they try to
take me out early you know and I'm still
here so no that's crazy